he's my favorite late late night host
you can see him every weekday night on
nbc and his very own show
late night with seth meyers you haven't
seen it you're dumb you should check it
out give it up for seth meyers
[Music]
yes how are you i'm wonderful how are
you doing
i'm a little tired today but that's okay
did you you knew that bobcat story
though that we just told
yeah happy i heard happy's in studio yes
happiness in studio
so i'm just saying we still have him on
the line do you have any other questions
for him i know that you've already
covered this yes first of all i just
want to say thank you to happy
we very much like talking about your
exploits on television did the
bobcats tooth actually hit your knuckle
bone
or was it just the knuckle part of the
finger no it
it actually um it it it stuck me in the
bone
i could feel it in the bone wow
i mean so happy you are a legend
you are a legend my friend because that
makes me think that you knew you were
throwing
a bobcat which was an incredible throw
by the way
whose tooth might have been attached to
your knuckle bone
i wouldn't go that far but you know
um yeah i'd have tossed that thing
as far away from me as possible like you
don't belong here sir
yeah you're in my territory
don't mess with my wife yeah i know i
love
that part that was just sweet um all
right my wife
said to me that the best i could do
would say
that's not true so wait do you like not
having to wear a suit every day
it's great i feel like you know i got
into comedy which is not a suit job
and then i was lucky enough to be a
weekend update anchor
and then that's a pretend suit job and
then you get late night and now it's a
full suit job because it we can update
we're wearing a lot of jeans underneath
the desk
yeah and this has been a real reminder
of why
i didn't want to work at a bank i love
not wearing a suit
and it's a lot easier getting dressed uh
when you don't have to um
put a tie on well my personal favorite
part of all of this
um attire-wise is people keep saying oh
my gosh like i don't even know what it's
like to dress up anymore because i'm
just like wearing like you know
athleisure like casual clothes all the
time and i'm like welcome to being a
musician
for the past 20 years i've lived on a
bus in one suitcase
wearing the same pajamas every day
because you you wear what you wear on
stage and then you wear normal clothes
you're just hanging on the bus
so like literally i have been in covet
attire for 20 years now
like that's what i've been living now
kelly did you ever
uh were you ever like a multiple costume
change concert
type of act yes unfortunately so how
many what's the most you wore on stage
in one night
maybe five and that's a lot i'm good
with like three
because i don't like to take the time to
do it because i'm more worried about my
vocals i don't think people are coming
to my show to be like i wonder what
she's wearing like so much as they are
like
how i'm gonna sound so yeah right i
could be wrong
i could just be lazy i think you're
right and i think it's it's true people
are there for your talent and look if
you want to put on three outfits for
them i'm sure they're not gonna mind
yeah i mean it's it's so time consuming
but anyway yes i've done it
okay so i have to ask um where are you
calling from
because it's kind of like the saddest
room ever i'm just gonna let you know
right now okay yeah thank you for that
feedback i do
before you say that you did notice the
one plant right
a single plant of the the sign of life
in the room
yeah um there were more plants but they
all left because it was so depressing
i know it's like we had to nail that one
to the table
just the one fern
[Laughter]
i'm actually i am in a uh i am in a
really
corporaty conference room which is where
we used to have like uh writer's
meetings and now is empty so we uh we
set it up for this but yeah i agree
i love that your writer's rooms by the
way though are the most creative looking
room in the world
well there actually is usually like fun
stuff behind us
okay behind me on the wall that's like
writer's room based but uh
a lot of it's really inappropriate for
television okay so wait when you're on
my show
last spring i confess my love of
cleaning out my ears it's weird how much
i love to do it
um but what's one habit of yours that
you would like to confess now do you
have one
that's weird i'm surprised i haven't
confessed it to you before but i told
you how much i love to floss
you do i love to floss i'll eat
food that gets stuck in my teeth just
for the purposes of flossing wait are
you making fun of me
no i love to floss do you not like to
floss
i i don't know if i'm like the best
person that comes in the dentist
usually i'm the one that leaves and
they're like you could floss a little
more mm-hmm
for me it's not like the maintenance
flossing
like the you know i know you're supposed
to like floss at the end of the night
i only like flossing it's like i know
there's something in there so like for
me
it's getting like buy a bag of jerky and
a thing of floss and that's just like my
afternoon
well first of all i'm definitely down
for the jerky because that's awesome
um but that's right you're right that is
weird um
so i don't know anybody that loves that
um but what's up for this
seems like weird that like the cleaning
her ears lady is going to look down her
nose at the guy who flies
here's the thing you know you should
look down at me i
people it's it feels good
you're right i'm the weird one here um
okay
so what's up for this summer because
we're starting to get our lives back are
y'all gonna do do you wanna do vacation
do you all do that kind of thing like go
big
yeah we'll go spend some time um with my
in-laws
and uh they're they're near a beach
which is great i'm not very handy
and my father-in-law tom is incredibly
handy and the other day my son found a
piece of wood that he wanted to turn
into a boat
and he said i am sad that you don't know
how to build things but i am lucky
that grandpa does
i don't know why i had to get dragged
into this that's amazing and so
sad well not many can whittle not many
can do that so
no but he does he has like um his uh his
grandfather has a full like
you know work shed and i think it's
every uh my boys just love uh that
they're gonna spend the summer getting
to build projects with him
no that is super cool i do love though
that we have figured out in this
interview that you
won't save your wife from a bobcat and
you can't help your son build anything
well i'm busy flossing
so wait this is i love this is it true
that your dad had one rule for you when
you're a kid
like if you were going to lie like if
you got in trouble if you're gonna lie
it had to be a really good lie
yeah he hated when we lied in a way
that disrespected his intelligence
i remember one time he the first time he
left my brother and i
alone for a week my parents went on a
trip and we were probably
let's say 15 and 13. and then he came
home
and he said where's the mail and
we had cleaned up really fast and we
couldn't remember where we put the mail
because the house was a real mess
and so i said to my dad we didn't get
any mail
and he said for the first time
ever we went five straight days without
getting any mail
and i said yeah no mail came this entire
week
and then he sat on the couch and there
was a giant lump
because my brother had shoved all the
mail under a couch cushion
i love that you're dead that must be
where you get your hammer he was like
sit for five solid days nothing not a
bill so that was it those for the first
time ever we didn't even get a catalog
okay
sure that's an incredible coincidence
my mom loves nothing more than when
she's around the two of us
and my dad she like piles on my dad
because she thinks like my brother and i
will back her up
and we have to say hey i think what
would be great for this time where we're
all together
is if you were a little less critical of
dad
[Laughter]
no cause then all the fun would
disappear she literally like walks in
the door and she's like you're not going
to believe what this guy did on the
drive
but like relax
oh she likes the story um well before
before you go
um i asked jimmy um and maya whenever
they were here
uh memories of prince you know because i
heard about the huge 40th anniversary
snl party
and it sounds like the most epic party
in all of the lands
so what do you remember about that night
well i mean it was the party that only
exists
in like works of fiction you never would
have that many people
together again but i remember my wife
and i were weaving through the crowd
right as prince was on stage
and it's very strange you never think of
like famous people going like this
excuse me excuse me um but it was so
densely packed and uh i was doing the
excuse me and then just came like
you know my face came like this close uh
to beyonce
and i we were you know we our eyes met
and i just was like pretty cool party
right and she said
yeah and then we just kept going like
the momentum took us away
and uh my wife uh said wow you really
really killed that interaction
and then you better you better leave
your ringer on because you're probably
gonna get a call from beyonce
she said hi and then i said hi and then
it was over yeah
i don't know if you heard i was like
pretty cool party right and then she was
like yeah i'm like
we went pretty good all right late night
with seth meyers airs weeknights on nbc
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help